so welcome everybody to this uh question
and answer session about the documentary
the neighborhood storyteller
um we you know I I just want to take a
moment to say why we have this extra
extraordinary panel today because today
we have
um Dr Rana dejani who is the founder of
the Grassroots community-led program
called we love reading which asked me to
talks about in the documentary and we
are also joined by the protagonists in
the in the documentary
um Rashid and the the filmmaker uh
Alejandra Alcala and I'm going to ask
um my colleague daughter the journey to
narrate for us the beginning of this
idea for the documentary and introduce
both asme and Alejandra and my role will
simply be at the moment to tell you uh
who I am and who Dr tijani is and why
we're together here for you today
um I am Catherine panterbreak I'm
professor of anthropology health and
Global Affairs here at Yale University
um Dr dejani is professor at hashemat
University in Jordan
she is both a scholar and a social
entrepreneur
as a scholar Dr Johnny and I have been
working over several years on
understanding better cohorts of Syrian
refugee enjoying in host communities
with respect to Health and Social
inclusion as a social entrepreneur
what you need to know about doctor
Johnny Rana is that she is
um she's the founder of we love reading
um
which now has established more than 4
000 libraries run local in local
communities in over 60 countries in the
program that was imagined and undertaken
in Jordan in the first place and for
this work she's been recognized and now
uh with many awards she's been named one
of the most influential
um women Arab scientists in the world
but for this uh program we love reading
she's received in particular the 2021
lansen unhcr Refugee award and has been
named ashore social entrepreneur award
given the short social entrepreneur
award in 2022 which is part of the world
economic award that selects social
entrepreneurs and leaders around the
world and so she has this International
recognition for something that she
imagined and delivered and put together
in uh at the South local in Jordan so
Rana thank you for being with us asman
Alejandra thank you for being with us as
well
um and please introduce us yes thank you
for inviting us and holding this uh film
screening and thank you everyone for
being here both online and in person uh
so I'm going to introduce the film and
therefore introduce Alejandra and esma
as part of the story because I think
that's more entertaining it's more fun
uh so actually we love reading I started
in 2006 reading aloud in my neighborhood
just as you saw asthma was doing and
then I I transformed that into a
training program and to train people to
do what I did in Jordan uh fast forward
the Syrian unrest happened and many
Syrian refugees came to Jordan Jordan
has a Haven for refugees from Palestine
I'm a daughter of refugees I'm from era
Syria Yemen even Ukraine today we have
refugees from Ukraine so so I went to
zatary camp and I held a training there
and I trained Asana and asthma took the
training and as you see her life was all
transformed so asthma you know who she
was asthma is she's a young woman
fascinating amazing full of energy was
changing the world as for today is in
France she has been uh has a as a
refugee now moved to France and you can
guess what is the first thing estima did
as soon as she set foot in Paris
she gathers the children start reading
it out to them she immediately called me
and said I'm ready to go out to the kids
uh so sasma is a Powerhouse now uh the
big heart foundation which is a
foundation based in the Emirates has
just started the whole initiative of
funding and supporting refugees in the
region and so they contacted uh the home
storytellers of which Alejandra and her
father Francisco are the directors and
producers and owners of this initiative
of this organization and they're really
well known for many films they do
documentary films uh so
um Alejandra who is a graphic designer
specialized in Motion Graphics and
post-production as reading design she's
fascinating she's an amazing woman as
well just had a baby so her baby was
with us on camera a little while ago so
Alejandra and her father actually looked
around in the region where can they find
a real story of a woman who who although
as a refugee was able to make a
difference in her life and so they found
we love reading our program and they
contacted us and so we introduced them
to asthma and they spent all the summer
of 2021 filming asthma in Zachary and at
the rest is history you saw the movie
and the movie has up till now 19
nominations six Awards uh of them the
Toronto Film award the Mountain View
film award and and the document the
borders award and and it's just counting
every day they call me up and they say
there's a new one so we're really really
happy with that and there's many reasons
why and that's why we're going to have
this panel discussion with Alejandra and
Asthma uh to to tell us more about their
asthma's Journey Alejandra's journey and
how they they both are mirrors for each
other Alejandra the very close in Age
and and it's just fascinating to hear
them talk together uh so welcome to
asthma and Alejandra I'll be translating
for asthma in Arabic both ways uh and
and we want people online to post their
questions in the Q a we will follow that
and of course uh we after we have a some
q a with asthma and Alejandra will open
it to the people here so that you can
ask your questions as well and we're
excited to learn and and by the way we
created to go with the movie a book my
mama's magic which is actually SMS story
in English and in Arabic uh so you could
take copies of these books and look at
the children's book that follows esma
about in the eyes of her daughter I mean
you saw her daughter in the movie so
this children's book is written from her
daughter's uh voice and her vision of
how she sees her mom and how her mother
changed and inspired her as well
all right so let's begin and Catherine
you're going to lead us and talk about
how as somebody who's been involved in
the research because we've done a lot of
research about we love reading to really
understand uh how the program is
impacted asthma and millions of others
and how can we learn from that to inform
other kinds of programming to do them
right and we'll talk more about that as
well first I think the we'd like to talk
to uh esma to start with her the
protagonist to share with us
her feelings about being you know as she
said in the movie that she wanted to
become famous and a writer and people
who want to have pictures with her well
actually she got her wish so some last
score about that I think we'll kick off
with that question and then we'll go
um
foreign
is that she wants all the young girls to
believe in their dreams and that yes
dreams can come true uh and all they
need to do is just dream and think big
and Trust themselves and have confidence
in themselves
um Alejandra over to you so I'd love you
to share how you first encountered uh
wheel of reading and then asthma and how
that you know really inspired you uh to
to create this movie
hi everyone
um Ron a great introduction
um and it's it's so great to be here I
really feel honored
um so actually this was like a really
unique opportunity because when the big
heart foundation approached us they gave
us like a white paper
um they did a brief that was very open
um and it gave us the freedom to be able
to to find something that as filmmakers
would Inspire us as well so that was a
really interesting opportunity and we
did a lot of research we found a lot of
amazing organizations out there but I
think what rang a bell with we love
reading
um was I think it's it's first of all
it's uniqueness
um and something that was uh really like
beautiful about the magic of reading and
we thought oh there could be like
something
um in the end it's it's also art and we
thought that it could be very
interesting uh for the film
um and the more we got involved in
Reading about what we love reading does
we realize that
um and after obviously conversations
with Rana we realized uh about that
reading is the bridge for something
bigger and and that that was the most
amazing thing and when Rana told us it's
a two-day training and when we heard
about asthma's story and how she
continued for years and years and the
life transformation that not only
brought to her but it also brought to
her community
that that was I mean that was probably
the moment that we said oh my God this
organization we have to we have to
collaborate with them and then
um I think it was us that suggested
meeting ASLA because we found an article
on your website Rana
um and so we we got introduced to asthma
and I think from the three first seconds
of our conversation we fell in love with
her because what you see on screen is
the real asthma and it's her laugh her
eyes
um the way she expresses and her desire
to not only like it goes so much further
her her wish to make a change in the
world and that is what captivated us and
and and and hearing her story and seeing
that if we were able to make this into
into a film that we could share with the
World Imagine how much larger her voice
could be and how much larger her impact
could be
um in the lives of of many especially
women and girls in situations like her
oh thank you thank you Alejandra for
sharing how this whole thing started
that's amazing Catherine do you want to
please no please continue I mean um I
guess that's not has to participate in
Arabic so yeah so so I'll just explain
it
foreign
[Music]
so I asked asthma how was her reaction
when she knew that they were going to
come and make a movie about her so she
said uh well first of all there was a
lot of phone calls going back and forth
introducing them to each other because
Alejandra we went through a lot of
loopholes to get them permission to go
and exactly with all the cameras uh and
all the equipment and it was a covet
time and it was la la and so and there
was limited time and they were on a
right and there was like they had to
finish within a certain period of time
but we were able to do it all and Asthma
says that she became very close friends
with Alejandra which they are they talk
all the time especially after this movie
they're being called every um a couple
of weeks for a screening or to give a
talk or something uh and so asthma said
it also made her get to know more people
and other people the film crew to think
of uh you know a different perspective
of life
all right we have another question
Catherine please
um a question for Alejandra I know that
um you know people might be curious to
see what it takes to do a documentary
like this you have obviously you know
you're obviously for portraying uh young
girls talking to you about their
aspirations and it's very moving in that
way they see very precious interesting
things like I want my life to matter and
to be somebody but what is the you know
like Rana just mentioned many cameras
you know to have to get permission to
Etc can you tell us a little bit about
what it takes to do a film like this
from the technical point of view and
from the organizational point of view
not just the inspiration
yes I can of course
um I just wanted to add a little bit of
a tiny um back end of the first question
um that I will never forget what uh Rana
said to us when we first spoke about the
magic that happens after the training
program and I think that was kind of um
a thing that triggered us to make this
documentary because uh asthma was not
only repeating what she had learned in
the training course that she did for for
many many years to come but it but she
had gotten to a point where she had
taken the skills learned at we love
reading and transformed them into a an
initiative that came from her heart and
that's why she
um was trying to gather girls that had
lived or were facing a situation that
she had lived in her past and that had
left a scar that she needed to to cure
um so uh I just wanted to add that card
and then regarding the the how we how we
did it technically and all the cameras
it was a lot a lot of work and a lot of
persistence and a lot of patience
um it on on one side the technical part
and the logistics
um was very difficult because of course
it's in a foreign language
um it's in a country that that you know
I mean I had never worked there before
so you don't really know how the
bureaucracy is and how you have to find
the permits um so we were lucky enough
to be able to work with the Royal film
Commission in Jordan who was um really
helpful
um while getting the the permits and we
also had good Fran from the we love
reading team who was our local fixer
um which is a very good friend of asthma
as well and funny enough both all three
of us are practically the same age so we
we all became really good good friend
um and so it was it was really difficult
and I have to add another challenge was
that we were facing covid so
um each time that we were able to
finally it seemed that the permits were
going to come out there was some sort of
delay in the travel
um because of covid and we had to re
um re-uh
I I forgot the schedule yeah like
reschedule and remake the permits and so
maybe some of our team members uh had
other prior commitments that and they
couldn't work with us anymore so we had
to find backups and it was an ongoing um
process for months and months even when
we arrived in Jordan it seemed we had
all the permits for all our team members
and unfortunately our photographer our
Director of Photography did not have a
permit to enter zathari so from 20 days
of filming it was reduced to 14 days and
we had and and the time that we had
applied for was to have the entire day
at Satay and it was reduced to leaving
at three in the afternoon and we were
followed by a policeman who was like
forcing us to leave at 3 pm Sharp so um
we had to work around those challenges
and as documentary filmmakers these are
kind of the surprises that you that you
find along the way
that's the the technical part
um the the story part and um and being
able to
to not make people panic when you have
thousands of cameras there which we
didn't we we're a very small team and
that's something that we take care of a
lot
um because we know it can be
intimidating but part of our process and
what's really important to us and a
priority is being able to gain the trust
of the people who's who are sharing
their story with us to film
because if you don't have trust you
don't have anything and and so that was
something that for months prior to the
the filmmaking itself
um asthma and I uh exchanged letters we
exchanged phone calls I asked her to
keep a diary I I shared with her
intimate things about my life as well
because it's a it's a two-way
relationship it doesn't work one way
um and I think that really helped for
when I arrived at asthma's door to be
able to to not arrive as a stranger
anymore and I and Asthma I mean I can't
even say like how amazing she is in
person in front of a camera behind the
camera at all times
um so that was that was amazing to see
and with the girls
I think um I think the first days they
were a little bit scared
I'm I'm surprised
um but I think it was very important
that they saw that asthma trusted us and
if they trust asthma they trust us as
well
um so that that was really helpful and
again we're a small small team
um and uh so so we don't want to make
too much noise in the room and that
helps as well
thank you yeah and I and I I would like
to I think also being a woman as well oh
yeah that makes a huge difference for
that trust in that relatedness uh and
I'll never forget when you said that you
were pregnant at that time right and I I
got pregnant after editing well I mean
when you were doing all the editing and
oh yeah and you said like you just
realized that you and us were the same
age and you were having your first baby
and just relating those human things
that were all the same in the end right
that we're all humans and we share
different there's similar experiences
although in different contexts and and
that shared humanity is something that
we need to keep reminding ourselves of
which you showed in the movie yeah
asthma I would like to ask you I'll ask
it in English and then I'll translate in
Arabic yeah I I would like you to share
how what was the process of change
within you after you took the training
and how did the uh how did that inspire
you to or change you to go out and do
another project which is the project
that was actually later on filmed with a
teenager groups because we love reading
is with the younger children is
foreign
[Music]
when she started reading aloud to the
children this led to an openness about
her she had just had a miscarriage she
was feeling depressed and not feeling
well like very optimistic and so through
the reading aloud with the children it
inspired her to have a love of Life uh
psychologically she became more positive
she had a a reason to live uh she was
more present I'm trying to translate
Verbatim what she said that the
relationship with the children she was
reading aloud to uh inspired her passion
and made her give her a sense of
belonging and that's when she's realized
that someone because again she started
reading aloud in 2014. so after a couple
of years some of the girls who used to
come grew up they became 13 14 years old
and so they stopped coming because they
thought this is just for little children
and that's when she because of that
feeling of like passion and openness and
reality and I am here I exist and of
course she went through other things she
became a writer for their local magazine
she wrote a children's book uh she
became a teacher in the local school in
Zachary
so all these little things uh inspired
her that oh what she identified a gap
and the Gap was that these teenager
girls uh were had before coming to the
read aloud so she had to create
something for them and that inspired her
to start her program let's read that you
saw in the movie uh where she started
Gathering the teenager girls and she
also designed it to cater to the needs
of these teenagers so she chose books
that were self-help books skill based
books so that they would learn these
skills whether they got married or not
but it was their decision to think okay
what can I do with my life and and she
wanted subtly inspiring them to go and
get your education and you don't have to
necessarily follow the path that you're
you know your community is prescribing
for you but you can think on your own
and you saw that through the
testimonials of the teenagers as they
were rethinking how they see themselves
in in this world and in their own
community
uh you have a question oh Asner it was
uh
it was a hard question I wanted to uh
say how impressive it was that you gave
this message of personal change
um and I wanted to ask you whether you
also felt that there might be or not uh
some inter intergenerational change so
how does that affect you know
um
the maybe your own children now of
course you are in Paris
um they see the world and you see the
world in a different way but I wanted
you perhaps to comment on anything about
whether that sense of personal worth and
purpose and work and service had changed
not only you as an individual but your
community around you and the Next
Generation
Catherine you know
hello foreign
foreign
of course the impact was not only on her
but on her children and her community
uh that this positive feeling uh this uh
how she changed and how she changed her
perspective affected them but she
elaborates a lot more about going to
France so she said when she went to
France that her positive energy was was
Transcendent it was very contagious and
she says this is something that she
learned from Reading because when you
read uh you learn about other people you
become more empathetic so everybody was
telling her don't you have a cultural
shock when you went to France she said
no I don't and she says it's all because
she reads a lot so and and she's also
inspired through we love reading as we
always say is not just to read to learn
about others but also to tell your story
to have that confidence about telling
your story so she tells her story and
she tells it to inspire others and to
share her positive energy with others
and those are her words and that's what
she does in France and inspires uh all
the people around her
um I'm going to add something just in
the spirit of all this which uh with to
me was something that I uh it was a
reflection so to speak you watched the
documentary and uh and you saw it was
actually esma's story it's not the story
of we love reading
it's not the it's not my story who
founded it's asthma's story and inherit
in that is a big big lesson is that we
didn't want it's not the story of we
love reading because if it's the story
of an organization then we're removing
the humanity from the people that we are
trying to uh work together with and and
this is very different this is unique
this is very special and it was a
collective effort of all of us to make
sure that we love reading was subtly
there
and that it was the rearing did not
Empower us as was empowered she has it
in her like every one of us we all have
it's how we evolved this is a species as
humans it's just that we need a little
Catalyst right an activation energy to
rekindle that fire that for different
reasons may have you know needs a little
bit of rekindling and wheel of ring just
does that it just nurtures it rekindles
it but like it's her story and that's
why we love reading it's actually every
person's story and they own it and it's
that
um we call it our secret sauce or the
magic right it's it's that that agency
that they feel I can do anything and
then they go around and do everything
and anything around them and Asthma is
their epitome example of this and I I
think that's a lesson for uh for program
development and program interventions in
international ngos as we develop
programs to serve to support uh uh using
in humanitarian context or in
development how do we develop use using
that strategy and that approach because
then it's sustainable
estimate care is the program wherever
she is you don't have to do anything
um and and and it will be taken up
because it belongs to the person who
actually did it because asthma did it no
one else and of course nobody this is
not about money either right that's my
did it because she cares about her
community she cares she belongs and she
talks about this feeling of belonging uh
to my community to my society and that's
why I do it because I care I read a lot
to the kids because I care I identify
challenges in my community and come up
with Solutions because I care and I
think that trust which Alejandra talked
about and that's all talked about that
trust that we need to Foster between us
as human beings is so important
sometimes we forget it and I and I think
it's really really important
um so I just wanted to touch on those
because I think that's a a huge Learning
lesson uh for for all of us and to me I
keep reminding you on yourself of that
uh so I think uh do you have any
questions or should you open it to the
audience we should open the magic please
yes
so who would like to ask uh start or
comment or critique by the way I love
critique because when you critique
that's how we learn if everybody's gonna
say oh this is great we're never going
to learn so please bring it on
how did Alejandra and Asthma communicate
a great question Alejandro I don't know
if everybody can hear can you hear that
did you hear that the question is how
Alejandra communicated
it's not it's funny you always find ways
to communicate
if there's a need there's a way
um and uh in the uh via virtually it's
easier because I um downloaded this
translator that automatically translates
my WhatsApp so I was talking uh to
Arabic and sorry in Arabic to asthma
through WhatsApp
um and funny funny enough after we
created the film now she talks English
to me via WhatsApp so she's the trans
she's translating now
um and then we exchanged letters so she
would share them in Arabic I would
Google translate them and then I would
share mine in English she would Google
translate
um and for the film we actually hired a
spontaneous sorry a simultaneous
translator
um so she Emma her name samani
um she did a great job by the way I
don't know who has that capacity to like
be hearing something in one language and
translating it into another one
um she was in a different room from
where we were filming uh connected to
the microphone that we were using so she
would hear
um asthma talking
um she would then translate into a
recorder that was connected into my
headphones and to the director of
photography's headphones
um and so we were hearing the English as
she was talking and the recorder that
that Amani was uh talking to we used
afterwards for the editing process
um so we used one channel that was in
English and then one channel that was in
Arabic so I could use one ear for one
language and the other for the other one
um and so that helped us make this basic
cut from all the footage that we had
um then eventually with um with a guide
of what the story was going to be how
the story was going to be told we then
sent out to translate to a company that
actually hires refugees
um so we wanted to to to also be able to
to continue you know supporting Refugee
self-reliance in that way as well
um and everything that we didn't
understand
we actually I I think that played in our
favor because you start to um focus more
on the emotions and the human behaviors
and how someone is acting and I think
that was captured um in asthma's uh
project with the girls we if you can you
can tell that during the entire film we
focused on the Expressions on the faces
so many times when we weren't hearing
Imani because it was hard for her to
translate when the girls were laughing
and talking all at the same time
we were just signaling like this girl
this girl this girl her face and it was
really emotional and I think that played
in our favor
another question yes please the girls in
the movie did you select them or are
they the whole set
so Alejandra can you hear that yes yeah
okay yeah please go ahead no no we
didn't want to intervene at all in in
the in the storyline um we left asthma
that that joke she selected uh she
created the project she designed
everything uh she selected the girls we
actually didn't know the girls until we
were actually there when Asma introduced
us she actually got the permits from the
families to be able to have the consent
for filmmaking
um she solved anything regarding the
project it was her all her so maybe I'll
ask her the question right yeah
um
so she when she selected the girls for
her program because again she's not
doing this for the movie right this is
what she's actually doing uh so the
girls she selected she wanted to make
sure that they came from diverse
backgrounds so they could learn from
each other and share from each other so
some were in school some were out of
school remember this was in the middle
of covid right
um and she also uh invited girls one of
the girls was actually engaged uh almost
to be married she wanted her to also be
part of the program so that she could
learn what other opportunities she had
even if she was married that she can
still do things and it's in her hand if
she pursues the path of reading and
education education is not just the
school right we can educate ourselves in
different forms and in different ways
and and actually one of the young girls
uh I don't know if well you wouldn't
know I know them all and she was
actually before this aspa had trained
she came to asthma and asked her could
you train me how to read aloud so I can
start reading aloud to the children so
when she was a little bit older she
started Gathering the kids and reading
aloud to them and then she became part
of SMS program for herself
um any other question yes James
uh it's really a pleasure I I guess I
found myself wondering uh have you been
able to interact and hear from the
fathers and uh what kind of perspective
they have and I guess it's really
fascinating to think about watching the
movie and sort of being interconnected
and I guess I'm just curious about sort
of where they stand in this reality but
uh thank you so much it's really
inspiring
thank you thank you well this is for
asthma is
um
[Music]
this is
so she's saying in terms of her own
personal story uh she was always very
close to her father and when she was
young she would go to his library and
read his books although there were much
uh I mean High uh well above her
level of of reading right most of them
would be uh more very Theory or
um above her I don't want to use the
word standard but I understand yes yes
now in terms of her project she wanted
to build that relationship between the
girls the teenager girls and their
fathers uh in in in the community that
she's part of girls are closer to their
mothers I think all over girls are
always closer to the mother that's just
how things are uh so she wanted to close
that Gap and
strengthen the relationship so when she
went as you saw in the movie she would
talk to the father about her project
explaining what it's all about to gain
his trust and under an understanding of
what it's about and she would encourage
the girls to go back home and talk about
the program with their fathers right so
they would share and create a dialogue
an exchange between the father and the
daughters so uh to to strengthen that
relationship
um maybe as I had seen that time
um
[Music]
foreign
yeah okay so as uh so asthma and she
follows up and talks about how I
followed up with a question about what
was the uh feedback from the fathers
right to follow up on your question and
she said
um the fault for the fathers it was
difficult at first to agree uh for the
girls to go outside their home and
participate in activities and she said
this is understandable because they're
coming out of a war and and that has its
own the trauma of being you know
protective about your family protective
about your children
um but eventually they would comply and
change she said uh opposite the mothers
they were more compliant and they would
say yes take them and and teach them uh
but you have to make sure that we
convince the dead right so she had to
convince the fathers uh so that they
would allow their daughters to come and
then I followed up with a question about
her husband because we saw her husband
in the movie Andy who was very
supportive of how they play role in the
beginning if you noticed they were play
Rolling right knocking and and getting
he was giving her a hard time telling
her that's what you're going to expect
from these fathers and she said at the
beginning her husband he's part of the
community and these are the expectations
of the different roles of women within
that community and taking into
consideration the war right because that
changes we I don't know how many of us
have been experienced more it changes it
changes your values and not your values
but what are your what are your fears
right where where you're scared and you
want to be protected so she said at the
beginning your husband
um it was not very supportive of her
activities in doing things but she said
it's my role her role and the role of
woman and to believe in themselves and
to have the confidence and persistence
to show that this is my passion I
believe in this I want this it's good
it's good for me it's good for my
community and it was her persistence and
her passion uh that and the work that
she did on the ground that proved to her
husband that yes this is making her
happier it's making her a better person
uh she's actually doing things making a
difference in the community so he became
her staunch supporter in many many
things and more than she's expressing we
know intricately things that she faced
and her husband was the staunch
supporter in in supporting her giving
being her back as she continued in the
different activities in her community
and and and maybe
um
um I want to touch on this and invite
Catherine because we're doing research
on this right trying to understand uh
the relationships between the mothers
and the father so the stretches on it
and more broadly on what is the impact
of we love reading on well-being and
happiness and what what is the mediator
of that right is it the agency is it the
motivation to lead what are those the
social networks so we've been working on
this and I'd love to hear from you oh
um
that's a well quickly um you mean on the
on the program and on the feelings of of
women yeah so I think uh you know I
think one of the surprising things what
our research touches many different
facets but one of the uh things that
we're trying to understand when people
use the word agency and empowerment and
she says I have tried to change from
within how people understand that
process of change and how it relates to
therefore not just your personal
psychological life satisfaction and
well-being but also how that changes
your ties with the community which is
about networks and how those ties change
the opportunities that you have to learn
work and
um and Thrive I think that's that's the
idea we're testing that with groups of
women Syrian and Jordanian who are or
not taking this program program we love
reading so it's a randomized control
trial we do this to have the best
scientific evidence of of what such a
program as an example our program can
show with outcomes on the individual on
Society on the learning uh learning
capacities of children basically
um you know if I were a poet I would say
on the body the mind and the brain and
the Soul so so so that this little this
little pieces to understand the value of
such program but if I may say so too and
I think you Alhambra you touched on that
which was extraordinary it is a two-day
non-paid
program of uh of basically of enabling
people to make changes in the place that
they are and so it's a very simple idea
that's why it's can be exported to
different places it's a very grounded
idea so kudos to you right now for
finding something that um is grown out
of your own experience and speaks to
that experience of other people well
yeah I could just draw the woman and who
are actually doing it but thank you for
sharing that I want to say it's not just
women oh yes so so so that's important
too it's it's young people and in and uh
and so Rana also you know told me one
day it was about changing mindsets and
to change mindsets you have to identify
the change makers in your communities
and I was oh mine says change makers I
remember those words but the change
makers do not necessarily need to be
women they can be men they can be youth
they can be anyone to anyone absolutely
and actually touching on that I want to
emphasize another point is that we we
love reading is a program developed
within the community by the community I
belong to that Community I have Siri and
have Palestinian I'm not somebody who
came abroad that said I want to develop
a program so I'm from the community and
I think that inherent in that is the
success is because when you develop for
yourself you know better where that
challenge is coming from and you know
better to develop a solution that works
that's practical uh that doesn't burn
you out that's and and to me uh for
three years as I was developing a
program meaning trying it myself trial
and error trying or in my neighborhood
reading aloud to the children I feel it
was the uh people call it now
human-centered design and what s was
doing with her teenagers right she's
developing a program with the girls as
she moves well I I liken it to Evolution
I'm a biologist right so it's it's that
natural selection you know trial and
error trial and error until you get it
to the most you reduce it to the most
empirical formula where with the least
input you get the maximum output
and that's what really reading is about
and the reason uh I mean people talk
about scaling I hate the world right why
because it employs it implies that I
have something and I know better than
you right and that's not what we love
reading about and so what you said I
think you use the word diffusion
diffusion or yeah it's like a movement
people pick it up right so uh we uh so
that's why our logo is changing mindsets
through Reading to create a change maker
so we're using reading as that Catalyst
for people to unlock their inner
potential realizing if I can do this
what else can I do so it's really
changing the mindsets of people around
the world so every person becomes a
change maker within her community and
and uh so it's it's changing the wording
and I think this is part of systems
change in the world I mean we have these
Paradigm shifts that people are talking
about how do you change the system so it
changes by how you design the terms you
use the definitions that we use uh to to
make that shift in the framework of how
things are done
so so Rana is a social entrepreneur he
can you can she has the idea and the
the perseverance and the passion to see
that we are partnering because of
research but I just want to say
Alejandra for instance you're very
integral in this because you are the
person who partners with
Esme and with Rana for example to to
show and you know you show and tell the
story and that's a really remarkable
partnership I think
um and so thank you for making that
documentary uh because otherwise without
you it doesn't have the coverage that it
deserves yeah yeah I I think that um as
reading is the Catalyst film is also a
catalyst for the same thing to defuse a
message that that should be um hopefully
brought to inspire many many more lives
and I think I just wanted to add um
regarding this conversation what what I
think is
um also makes things very successful
like change very successful is that both
asthma and around and for example
um are are giving a message that they
are model I mean they're modeling
something that they do for themselves so
for example
um asthma is talking to the girls about
having a good relationship with their
father and she is going with her father
and building that relationship uh she's
talking to the girls about dreaming big
and here she is
um giving conversations and and in
discussions and giving the message
um and she imagines herself outside of
Jordan and here she is
um Rana wanted to start a we love
reading program and she was there
reading to children so I think part of
um of this whole idea of creating change
is also being the change that you want
to to to bring to the world and I think
that's why they're both so so successful
and and everybody can be that I think
and everybody can be yeah and it doesn't
have to be meaning we have to become do
it big we always tell it's about the
small steps it's about doing the small
things and being persistent uh which is
the chaos theory in physics right when a
butterfly flutters its wings uh it moves
the air a centimeter but there's a huge
change in time and space beyond what we
can imagine and actually uh both me and
Asthma we draw this from our religion as
Muslims both of us where in Islam it
tells us be the guardian so take care of
your community and it says do not
belittle any good even if it's small do
it you're not responsible for the
results you're responsible to try that's
because you can control trying but you
and that's all you need and I think any
person can
um inside you you know that if you
really want something and you go and do
it things will happen eventually
um so I I want to ask esma a question so
that as we wrap up I don't know if
anyone has any burning questions that
you would like to ask yes please
summary
yeah
um
foreign
because he works in he reads feminine
literature I'm translating in English
when you can say it but it's okay uh so
as I responded that uh she reads books
by uh she mentioned a particular author
so he's a I I personally don't know him
but I'm assuming he writes a lot of
books uh about self-help she's really
inspired by books that are about
self-help changing your personality
improving it another person she reads is
um
foolish a little bit
act foolish and we can see them here
it's okay act foolish maybe that's the
best uh paraphrasing
um and she's also read the the book by
Malala
and she read my book which I'm gonna say
because I want people to to and the
reason I'm saying it is I want to
inspire others to write their story
right it's not that my story is very
special I'm sure there are millions of
special stories but we need to write
them and and I say this to whoever is
listening on zoom and and to the young
students here is that the most of the
literature is written uh from one
perspective by the global North and we
need to read the stories of people
coming from the global South for lack of
a better word I don't like Global South
either but I have to just portray what
I'm talking about to write our stories
because we need we owe it to ourselves
and we owe it to the next Generation to
hear our stories and our voices and I'm
sure Esther's gonna write her story
right
yes and then you know um Alejandra you
said something so in promoting for the
movie we really prepared the whole
package right Alejandra and one of the
slogans is we want to we want to inspire
a million estimates like help us have a
million estimates around the world and
I'm sure if there were the world would
be in a much better place than it is
today uh I don't Alejandra you want to
comment on that yes
um so after we created the film um we
wanted to stop producing films for a
while
um and work with asthma to be able to
design a strategy that can
um Can diffuse this film further and
this message further um and so while we
were talking with asthma we asked her
like what would be your dream with this
film
um and you're like your highest goal and
so she told us that she wanted to
inspire women and girls
um in situate invulnerable situations
like hers or others of other situations
um to be able to to dream and to
continue their lives with whatever
um situation or adversity they may be
facing
um and so that became our primary goal
and uh we decided to
um partner with more organizations
around the world that have the the means
to be able to reach um our target
audience
um and through the film use the film as
a tool to be able to inspire educate and
Empower
um more women and girls we also suggest
to any partner organization that wants
to use the film
um to empower more girls to to talk
about their empowerment programs because
as Rana said
um we we didn't really mention we love
reading in the film because it's
asthma's story and the awesomest story
can Inspire
um more people and if it if it takes
another empowerment program to to be
that um that little push that as uh that
Rana is talking about in Soviet if that
will help and support and enable more
assets in the world
um so that that's our impact campaign
with this Villa and it's it's moving
along smoothly so far
all right so as we end uh I want to ask
if asperham wants to share a final word
um
uh come on
foreign
about the girls in the picture in the
end when they were all uh together like
where does she see them in the future
and she says I'm I tell them that if
they believe something then it can
happen if they believe in it enough and
if in order to achieve it it's they have
to believe and they have to work hard
enough for it and it will happen and
that she still is in touch with these
girls and she tells them I don't have to
be beside you you need to learn to
depend on your own selves uh her last
piece of advice and she's saying amongst
you are either fathers and mothers now
or will be in the future that listen to
your girls believe in them believe in
their dreams and their ideas because
even if they appear to be simple or
silly they are important to them to the
girls so listen to them support them
because they are the future and and she
says and and these girls their dreams
will come true her daughter Tamara I
always dreamed of being in a forest
among a lot of trees and you saw Zachary
right there were no trees and now she's
in France where there's a lot of trees
so her her dream has come true in that
sense and she thanks everybody as well
so over to you so
um we need to close I want to thank you
all for being with us today I want to
thank Rana for being with us in person
uh I want to thank esma for coming from
Paris I want to thank Alejandra for
coming from Barcelona I believe
um and I want to thank you for being
with us also of course I want to thank
three programs that made this possible
the programs of really of refugee forces
placement and humanitarian responses at
the MacMillan the program on conflict
residents and health at the MacMillan
Center of Yale and the program on global
health studies so thank you very much
and I hope your journey continues thank
you
[Applause]